I'm glad we caught you at home.
Could we use your phone?
We're both in a bit of a hurry.
Right!
We'll just say where we are
Then go back to the car
Please to meet you Dr Frank-n-Further
We don't want to be any worry.
Well, you got caught with a flat
Well how about that
well babies don't you panic
by the light of the night
it'll all seem alright
I'll get you a satanic mechanic
I'm just a sweet transvestite
From Transexual Transylvania.
Why dont'cha stay for the night?
night
or maybe a bite
bite
I could show you my favourite obsession
I've been making a man
with blonde hair and a tan
and he's good for relieving my tension
I'm just a sweet transvestite
From Transexual Transylvania.
Hit it!
I'm just a sweet transvestite
sweet transvestite
From Transexual Transylvania
So come up to the lab.
And see what's on the slab
I see you shiver
with antici...
...
..pation
But maybe the rain
is really to blame
So I'll remove the cause
But not the symptom